hey guys i'm ryan right hi i'm lauren
god and well i'm sure you guys have all
heard about Robin Williams and it's a
horrible event horrible tragedy but I
just really want to just do a quick
video because this guy really did touch
my life when I was younger like much
younger I remember growing up on mrs.
Doubtfire a lot credible it's like a
classic you know it's so [ __ ] funny
and then also him as the genie in
Aladdin would challenge me was birdcage
movies Dead Poets Society was dramatic
actor and oh yeah a Good Will Hunting
there's a movie he did with Robert
DeNiro called the awakenings I've seen
that the litters is one scene where he
breaks down and every single time I
watch it I just start to bawl my eyes
out like he's a fantastic actor he he
was one of those actors who just knew
how to feel you know like it was so
instinctual for this guy to just be able
to go out there and just go whatever he
feels like doing you know he had such
freedom and that's what was really
inspiring to me about it you know like a
lot of people say like when I perform I
like I kind of don't give a [ __ ] and
stuff and I think I picked up a lot of
that from him too because one thing that
I'll never forget this and I was really
young I think it was for the Fisher King
where's we're doing the video guys
there's for the Fisher King were one
where he said that in every single take
or every single moment
there's always something funny you can
do and a lot of the time comedians like
don't really think of that aspect of he
knew that any moment you could actually
make funny and you just all about
finding that and discovering that and
that philosophy kind of just got
embedded in me when it comes to anything
that's comedic you know and he also knew
how to have heart though at the same
time like he was just he was fantastic
he literally was fantastic yeah he will
definitely be missed but he's making God
laugh now yeah yeah absolutely free me
go laugh before you're probably right
yeah
Jesus laughed a lot too okay mm-hmm all
those religions left right yes something
like that that sounds right yeah but no
um you know like last year I had a
couple of deaths that happened in my
family and one thing I've really learned
and it sounds so cliche but it really is
the best thing you can do is really just
remember what was great about them
because you know from my understanding
it was a lot of people are suspecting
that I was a suicide and you know it's a
horrible way to go out and the guys who
struggle with drug addiction forever and
and but still like remembering like all
the great things he's done like I
remember even watching a stand-up comedy
special on HBO
he never done stand-up before I mean
wrong he had done sin before but yeah I
never had a special before and oh man
that guy was just he was something else
and I just wanted to say quick thank you
to Robin Williams for all the things
you've done for us we literally just got
the news a few minutes ago yeah I think
he's definitely touched a lot of
people's lives
including both of ours and I'm sure a
lot of people watching so yeah well
thank you Robin
you're a great guy and we'll see you in
the afterlife